to what extent is faith compatible with
doubt so early yeah I know you talked
about this you no doubt and and faith
and and how there they are well they are
compatible in a way they're not just
compatible they're essential mm-hmm
without doubt there is no faith
it's just belief that he's being pursued
that was awesome well let me let me
expand on on my thoughts on this really
quickly my pithy answer is we must
question what we hold close otherwise we
cling to everything and and I think that
if we've been sold something if we've
been told something since we were young
and then we refuse to question it then
how how strong is our conviction really
right if we're just given some template
and then we're told not to question it
then I think we're gonna have a really
weak faith in whatever it is is that
fair yeah absolutely III think a person
doesn't doubt doesn't think I put the
answer is faith and doubt are two sides
of the same coin it's funny because when
I read this question I almost didn't
really understand it cuz I'm like what
does doubt have to do with faith but
then I realized like doubt and faith it
really is this at least the way I take
it is it's this feeling that I get it's
going with my gut and a lot of the times
I forget where you mentioned in your
book but it's like tens of thousands of
negative thoughts that enter our mind
every single day that was a fascinating
quote stat here 60,000 thoughts a day 80
it's crazy so so we're bombarded with
48,000 negative thoughts a day like it's
it's actually no wonder Dayton happened
right right yeah so so for me it's like
we have to it's okay to have doubts it's
okay to have faith but to hold on to
those loosely and sometimes we have to
doubt our doubts and sometimes leave to
doubt our faith but I think you have to
push harder it's not just okay to have
doubts it's a it's not okay to not have
doubts man
Sean's gonna have like a million
tweetable answers here
you